frappez-le
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
hé
ralentissez
et mettez dans le trou l'
équipe de criminels internationaux le
plus grand braquage de pétrole de l'histoire
[Musique]
ce n'est pas personnel
ces gars sont un peu sur les nerfs vous
faites des surnoms hein pygargue à tête blanche Tomb
Raider
plein  divulgation il se passe beaucoup de choses
ici
je pense qu'ils vont te tirer dessus d'accord
parce que la première fois que je te vois je veux
te tirer dessus d'accord
je retire juste ce qu'ils font toujours
va haut je vais descendre d'accord je vais
bien tu vas bien lâche moi d'accord
[musique] désolé
dommage tu dois faire ça tout seul
je ne suis pas seul